j'étais vraiment hyper impliquée et que
et qu'on voyait ça de loin on pense que
que c'est là le moment dans l'année où
il va se passer quelque chose
d'incroyable par rapport au climat mais
il faut vraiment peut-être relativiser
nos attentes tout n'est pas terminé une
fois que la coop est terminée s'il en
résulte souvent des engagements en
grande pompe le travail se fait tout au
long de l'année et ce n'est surtout pas
le moment se décourager estime Léa et
lardo on peut avoir très peur des
scénarios à venir et ben on sait jamais
trop tard en fait pour chaque degré de
réchauffement qu'on peut éviter et donc
c'est ça qui à mon avis les cops montre
mais pendant 100 les coups anxiété
augmentent constamment les chercheurs
qui s'intéressent au phénomène
constatent une hausse importante chez
les jeunes particulièrement chez les
femmes le fait d'être exposé à autant de
changement climatique on les voit que ce
soit via les nouvelles les médias
sociaux etc ça peut vraiment venir nous
toucher parce que ça redéfinit nos
perspectives d'avenir alors comment ne
pas être submergé par cette détresse par
des mouvements qui sont très concrets au
quotidien
plus nous aider grandement même chose si
on est un parent et qu'on a un enfant
qui présente de l'écho anxiété ou un
adolescent qui présente de l'écho
anxiété ça peut être d'aider l'enfant à
faire ces gestes là Cara des milliers de
kilomètres de Charmel chèque ou se tient
la cop27 c'est d'abord et avant tout sur
nos petits gestes que nous avons le plus
de contrôle rappelle Catherine Raymond
ici qui me permettra aucun Canada
Montréal